[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars I'm Phil
Molina and this is rogue theory we've
got a rogue theory about endgame
surprise surprises are time Heights
going on but just in general this show
is the show where we bring very
wonderful people together from our pasts
oh these people but welcome back to the
channel
yeah you're doing you're doing so great
but also old friends last week he was in
this chair yeah you are embarrassing
when I first saw that next written down
I I thought it was latinx see I thought
it was adult films featuring Latinos
speaking of films that were watched by
adults Marvel made okay so there's this
this theory going around based on this
image that everybody now has the endgame
blu-ray and we go through the thing
frame by frame
oh yeah find any morsel we're gonna find
it but pretty interesting one came up so
when they are about to go into the time
heist and they're dealing with well this
is actually a later point
but that that system that they built for
the time travel when nebula is going
later and she is going to call 2014
Thanos goodness there's a quick shot of
the screen and if you're watching the
video version of this will put this this
image on on screen you can see faded out
that you can actually make out what
years they've been traveling to and very
specifically it matches up basically
with what the what the movie was doing
except one of them says 2988 which is
this is too big of a year my brain can
barely comprehend like 21 something
somewhere 2020 988 so on the cusp of the
millennium might be another William and
we don't know what the hell that's in
reference to yeah well there's like some
people have found something in the MC
past but I think there's like my mind
jumped to this so there's earlier in the
movie where before Tony Stark figures
out the whole inverted mobius strip and
how you can get these GPS things on your
wrists where you see Scott Lang he keeps
going back at different ages and you see
him as a baby seem as the toddler seem
as a really old man now Scott Lang was
just in quantum realm right yeah where
you get these like quantum healing
particles did something trigger his
aging process so that the old version of
Scott Lang that we saw as his old man
was from the Year 2019 Paul Rudd it does
not age so that's maybe there's a
version where that's that's that's what
we see Scott Lang and Paul Rudd have the
same aging mechanics real quick remind
everyone this shows about rogue theories
and we support them no matter how Road
so cameo so if it's Paul Rudd doesn't
age you're saying that he would live to
2988 and only look like what 40 years
older yes he looked 40 years old my bad
guys older than 40 yeah he said my back
and you saw an old man's face maybe it's
just skeleton and the rest of that
termites they were chiseling away this
bag they froze his head the way they did
okay I lay all great that rogue it's
gonna get weird after because it's
inspired by real life all right Leo
let's hear 2028 90 99 rogue hears I was
I was pitching this earlier I think that
the potential is here's so here's my
idea it is a hawk I had to go back and
give his son his baseball mitt that he
took away he's gonna retire because he
because he took that future because
after the snap everyone can live a lot
longer I guess or something you know the
whole magnetic waves these can be rode
theories right okay let's see yes
his size his son's baseball mitt went
missing when Hawkeye did the first test
right and so he needed to return that
baseball mitt or else his son wouldn't
fulfill his destiny of becoming a
major-league all-star in the year 2988
now this is his response to witnessing
his best friend commit suicide and you
know what
I should get back that baseball man well
he's probably thinking you know it's
important family cuz they're having this
whole thing about fit he's like you know
it's really important family and I took
my son's glove got to give it back if
you're looking your life at a quarter a
tie a quarter mile at a time those toys
cuz I want to see him yeah how many
ropes is half an inch taller okay but
you know let's see it again
[Laughter]
okay I feel like the audience I know I
feel like I know our audience pretty
well speaking of that I know that
there's you know eight to ten hundred
comments being written right now they're
like haha I love when they're having a
good time but could someone make a real
theory that might really murrini okay
maybe a little less Road okay this is
the year twenty nine eighty eight I
apologize this is more of a pitch for
the movie that takes place in 2029
2988 is that Thor who is eternal right
and Captain Marvel who I feel like has
gotten at least some life lengthening
like skills of some kind hair shortening
life lengthening what's her regimen
everything she's a man to like
suffocating in space so she probably is
immune to death of some kind so my pitch
is it's a buddy cop movie with Captain
Marvel and Thor in 2988 and they do
space future stuff and it's just a buddy
cop foam and that's my pick please call
it space
[Laughter]
you can't have this many Latin ex people
on the piano because weirdly how is it
that Eric's first theory is the only one
that even acknowledges the concept of it
being very far in the future
nobody köppen has the word future MLB is
apparently very similar I would say this
they may restart the MLB once everyone
comes because I was very mad that there
are no New York Mets I'll be baseball
there's a very sweet scene like around
the snapper tourney we're like some
players kind of like cornstalks there's
probably a million like hey Dad you want
to have a catch there's probably a ton
of that yeah
after Ironman snap everyone's coming
back and wanting to have one last catch
with their dad because they realize how
futile and fleeting life is talk about
2988 also on that screen was the year
2009 yeah and at no point in Avengers in
game does anyone go back to the year
2009 as we saw they might have happened
off screen and like in the MCU timeline
the year 2000 it's not really clear when
the events of Ironman take place some
people are saying it's set in the year
2009 that's when you know what iist and
tried to yeah accordion fascia layer
yeah so there's something interesting
there too that not uh people are asking
about like who went back to 2000 did
someone try to go back to the moment
Nick Fury recruited Iron Man Tony Stark
to join the Avengers is there something
back to that original first arc reactor
that people are trying to go back to was
there another like sub trip with Pym
particles to try to save Tony Stark with
his arc reactor when ant-man went inside
of him and like ruptured it I yeah yeah
but they don't involve the MLB so no
yeah 2009 probably a rough year for the
Mets most most years would be sports
jokes are at home here so I I do think
that's that's really I don't have any
guests for that no my only only ask I
don't have the answers my the only thing
that we do know about that 2988 thing is
if you do go look more closer you can
kind of make out it does seem like it
actually has a little switch next to it
as as bc instead of ad so if it's 2988
before jesus then jesus because it's
yeah then we're talking about the very
distant past but it does potentially
line up with the Asgardian armies battle
against the Dark Elves and Thor the dark
world yeah which is a battle where the
ether was there so this green like a
like a browser history is it like was it
the last place that's the implication
right so I guess the idea there would be
that maybe they went back to go get the
ether in a different attempt other than
sucking it out of Natalie Portman yeah
but it also feels like maybe they that
was gonna be the plan if they couldn't
pull off the Natalie Portman scene you
know what I mean 1970 maybe there was a
fallback exactly
maybe there's a fallback Marvel Studios
plan where they're like look we'll see
ya wasn't or that whole this is I mean
and it might be an actual theory I think
you talked about this the fact that like
there was gonna be Thor's Trek was going
to be completely different
yeah and the tomb so the idea like maybe
there was never any going back to Asgard
and meeting with your mom and that's
maybe that's never where you got this
and he probably wouldn't have been fat
in that version cuz that all lines up so
well with the concept of maybe running
into your ex is like oh so you're like
oh you're supposed to work out before I
thank to my star yeah maybe that's a
different place to get the sludge right
tomorrow would have happened the red
sludge yeah red sludge you
I mean it wasn't in the middle of the
movie they just at some point ant-man
Paul Rudd who never ages said yep that
we only have this many Pym particles
left there could have been any number of
attempts before that we did we just
didn't see that failed immediately like
they could have gone back to 2988 BC to
try to get it because that's some at
some point Thor told them that it's
there but and they're like that doesn't
work and then during this brainstorming
montage session that's when they finally
decide on their final plan but there
were a lot of other male attempts before
that final plan you know what some fun
idea with all those failed attempts is
when TV shows would kind of run out of
ideas and they would do an episode that
was kind of like you know a bunch of
just like a clip show episode if it's
just like clips of them trying to get
them a bunch of times but the Pym
particles mess all that up yeah they
said they only have a certain amount
that Pym particles thing messed up a lot
they only have so many yet people are
using it all the time in all kinds of
ways Santos brings an entire army back
with pimples also all you do is you keep
going back to the 1970s again and again
slightly different times and then you
wish for more wishes every time before
we talk about some very dark spider-man
news and some other stuff going on let's
thank the sponsors that helped bring
this weird conversation to life this
episode of rogue theory was sponsored by
post mates so it's 1:00 a.m. and you're
halfway through streaming the boys and
those gelato cravings are really
starting to kick in
no need to leave your couch just
postmates it post mates is your
year-round personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery service anything you're craving
post mates can deliver they're the
largest on-demand network in the US and
offer delivery from your favorite
restaurants grocery stores and anywhere
else you want things from 24 hours a day
365 days a year post mates will bring
you what you need within the hour
no more trips to the store you don't
even have to know where the store is
post mates will deliver anything to you
download the free app for iOS or Android
browser ocol restaurants and businesses
and track your delivery in real time and
for a limited time post mates is giving
our listeners $100 of free delivery
credit for your first seven
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use the code
rockstars
that's code rockstars for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days when you download the post mates
app anything you need anytime you need
it post made it download post mates and
save with code rockstars as we're back
the Joker
movie the standalone Joaquin Phoenix
movie that comes out on October 4th we
have been talking there's there's an
idea out there that actually we see this
movie very much as a standalone film
that is its own thing kind of a side
story or an elsewhere a world kind of
thing for the DC Cinematic Universe but
there's some theory that's like no it's
it's in the worlds that we've already
seen established either Nolan's films or
the Snyder films this version of Joker
somehow might exist in that scenario
already so I want to hear some rogue
theories about what that would mean how
would that play out in these films if
he's actually from the universe we
already know well I mean we're kind of
looking at this we already have sort of
a joker verse right like we have
multiple different jokers that already
kind of exist in a multiverse in our
reality rather than in universe in the
movies
but it's interesting that this Joker set
in the year 1981 I believe right you see
a child version of Bruce Wayne in the
trailer will be in the movie maybe in
the background
we'll see how part of the story he is
like clearly this Joker is set
generations before the other Joker's
that we've seen and it's going to be the
darkest version of Joker though this is
a first r-rated Joker that we have seen
go into what you think that means the
darkest version the darkest version
walking not I mean definitely Heath
Ledger some Jared Leto has did explore
some dark places all sending feces to
his co-star stuff was like not on film
at all the this is new walking phoenix
version the fact that he's doing it
r-rated they're basing it off of some
Scorsese stories like the King of Comedy
like taxi driver it seems like they're
really exploring the mental illness of
the character as opposed to one that is
more derivative or maybe just like
surface value they
have the freedom to really get to some
dark places by without our rating so I'm
wondering if at least in our world we
may see some version of like a joker
that is your one joker it truly is a
joker origin story and some people say
the Joker shouldn't have an origin story
that's what makes him the Joker at least
I was the case in The Killing Joke in or
at the ending of the kingly joke and in
the Dark Knight but I think we could see
a version of the Joker in this upcoming
film that you could say inspired the
later versions of Joker that we've seen
in past films insofar as they may be
copycats of that deranged mind and each
generation has its own Joker that is
specific to that world I'm gonna give
you a phrase and it's the church of
Joker I think that concept is what
they're trying to tap into and Batman
beyond the concept of chaos and
embracing chaos and disrupting not just
order but bureaucratic order and just
being like rules don't apply becomes
just this is but also in Dark Knight
Returns it's it spills over into like
the psyche of all of those criminals I
wonder if the Joker lends itself to that
that would be really cool just cuz like
I mean obviously I think it'd be--he'd
be retrofitting it but then that would
make something like the dark be opening
the Dark Knight that much more powerful
as opposed to always like cartoonishly
like thuggish guys it's just like oh we
all worship at the feet of this yeah
this alpha Joker and like now we're all
like following all these people in clown
makeup everywhere across the country in
the world I think that'd be super
terrifying yeah yeah like everyone who
wears clown makeup is actually paying
tribute to their spiritual leader it's
all occult so really we've known that
clowns are terrifying for a reason this
whole time yeah that's why people are
scared of clowns because of Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker take that rogue
he does not a rogue enough theory it's a
theory is right if it proves to be
correct she'll touch you with a
globalist hand just a touch of a nun
gloved hand okay let's be honest all
versions in there
and you apologize your own mind is
illegal we talked about this idea that
Joker could be like Santa Claus
spontaneously and not having just stolen
it from arrogantly oh but I'll say so
Eric's idea is that there was in the 80s
and then theoretically what he dies or
something happens but people take on
that so here's here's my rogue theory
capital R lowercase T while he's telling
his yeah so my theory is that the mantle
of the Joker is a little bit like Santa
Claus in the movies the Santa Claus and
the Santa Claus - where do you remember
the Santa Claus - so title I believe it
might be the Santa Claus find a mrs.
Claus so it's based on the mrs. space on
the mrs. Claus is the idea that if you
kill the Joker you become Joker you sign
that with
the Lords of light and good and evil and
you become the next iteration of the
Joker
we will definitely dive into that but
holy crap one second is that how Scott
Calvin gets I mean I know that he
accidentally okay Santa so you think
it's like you know you have to kill
Santa almost like to be the best you can
take is to defeat the teacher yeah so
it's to murder Santa yeah cuz rooms are
not Tim Allen murdered that Santa by
giving him a heart attack he didn't want
it but that was his plan all along yeah
that weakened heart from all the cookies
and milk way to rogue to Joker so you're
saying that they who killed who then you
have to sort of anchor it in one of the
iterations I mean I like I personally
like the idea that it's Heath Ledger's
Joker who murdered Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker and that those are somehow linked
and that the child Bruce Wayne in 1981
is Christian Bale's iteration
just I also think that might that might
work better age wise in right now then I
mean now there's gonna be several but
like the Affleck version or the patinas
inversion but yeah I think that'd be
interesting to see like to get to to
become the Joker that Heath Ledger
became here to kill Joaquin Phoenix and
I mean in real time so Joaquin Phoenix
is the oldest one and then Heath let or
right maybe no I maybe I'm getting
around but then Heath Ledger and then in
the future is like Jared Leto beyond
that in the future is Jack Nicholson and
way distant future is somewhere in their
blood like around his mouth yeah and
that's when the Joker I'm surprised you
actually got those numbers right the one
time when we weren't talking well we all
gotta go now any other lingering Joker
thoughts of how this Joker could be the
Joker that we are in our universe we
already know yeah so so like in the
Heath Ledger version the rise of Batman
sort of calls out or creates the Joker
right like he basically shows up because
there's a hero he's like oh you know it
tasted the theatrics he said because
he's got your style yeah yeah so my
there is basically the reverse so that
back in time child Bruce Wayne The Joker
already exists and he's the one who who
ends up killing Bruce Wayne's parents
and basically creates the hero for the
villain so it's the Batman the Tim
Burton Batman has done that Joe Chill
sorry I believe right but they that
actually weirdly I think has people a
lot of people think Joker killed Bruce
Wayne's parents but that is interesting
so he created him way back when and then
created which one the Christian Bale one
you're saying then no no I know I I
think because it's so dark it seems like
a separate thing to me um yeah so
universe to me Bobby Pattinson
parents I don't think it's gonna be any
of these I can't I can't see how they
can put it in the same universe because
it's it's kind of what you were just
saying it looks like it it totally would
mess a lot up the only thing that it
could be as if it is a set up for Robert
Pattinson universe but then you know
what they got to go equally into how
mentally ill that person is to become
Batman which is interesting but and
there have been some rumors that Robert
pattinson story the Matt rave story
could go into like an Arkham Asylum type
hmm story sucks and that is what ben
affleck sold script yeah going with
anymore delved into it with it that they
did save like they want to bring in the
rogue's gallery into the Matt Reeves
version and that could be how they do it
by having them all as current inmate
said it also really an age wise because
then it would be fun to have a movie set
in 2004 we all remember what happened in
2004 I believe the Red Sox won the World
Series you guys are killing it and so
spider-man what okay so comic writer so
this is a guy who's written a good
number of spider-man comics Dan Slott he
came out with this hot take this week on
Twitter saying there's nothing he does
not like an Avengers endgame and it's
that spider-man's straight up kills and
he has that high moral bar for
spider-man and a lot of people have for
Superman but he and generals kind of
like yeah like superheroes shouldn't
really kill people did kind of establish
hey spider-man has killed before but
those are pretty old comics or pretty
weird out there stories in in main
stories he's not really known as a
cold-hearted killer in this version it's
that moment where he activates the iron
spider student he says activate instant
kill we know that he previously did not
want to do that the first time he
accidentally turned on instant kill
alright so I guess our our question here
said straight up like is it okay if he
kills can superheroes kill can
spider-man specifically kill let's
remember he's a teenager yeah I mean I
didn't get depend to go first I think it
depends on the character cuz like Black
Widow kills you know I think probably
pre well she was like little before II
being drafted into the Avengers yeah and
it's not like they did she did it and
they were like you don't qualify because
you've
murder like they were like fine with
probably a pro yeah oh you have killed
that's great we're looking for someone
you know it's interesting that they
don't often go like Oh Black Widow you
have a lot of murders to atone for it
they like sound ways you have maybe it
is kind of like a thing but like it's so
weird that she killed she's the only one
like if she could be maybe the only one
I mean Hawkeye yeah what do you do like
I'm gonna nail his earlobe
I mean they've served like across like
overseas in battles I have to imagine I
mean Nick Fury as well like all these
people have killed they've killed other
men right so he just was a regular agent
yeah so and every FBI agent has killed
[Laughter]
yeah you know they must kill people like
some of those guys in that elevator
those Hydra soldiers must have had their
neck snapped or had chronic illnesses
and what kind of life where we talk
about at that point speaking of so so
Peter Parker has killed by neck snap
before - were you there were any of us
there were any of us in an elevator I
was and that's why I can't cheat Ari
must have had families I had friends who
were outriders no one's morning them so
so I think it's worth going into what
these outriders are - so Peter Parker
kills specifically the the instant kill
goes off on these outriders which is
kind of those for forearm 206 limbs
sure yeah likely oh please add two arms
to me for audio listeners we didn't
marina earlier was asking like like what
are those things are they like robots
really my thing is I was like I think
they're doggies yeah they're simply I
think
rained dog they're like trained
telekinetic dogs which is Sookie
telekinetic in the comics leg like no
one cares about reptiles yeah the
missing Easter egg is my home egg I've
just tried to find my way back to like a
salmon to kill anybody than like it's
very pretty hard to be a superhero
I got ok so then I'll put you in that
scenario the famous one right Zack
Snyder has Superman and Zod there and
Zod is literally just gonna like
assassinate a school group of kids and
all Superman has is kiss he has his head
in a headlock that moment are you guys
thinking like yeah like just give in to
that because that's one of those
controversial moments in modern
superhero films well I mean I think he
said he didn't even need to be that bad
a guy
apparently corny who doesn't mean yeah I
mean he said obviously that scenario set
up to make that choice like they wanted
him to have to kill though he should
have just told the kids like keep
inching that way I'm not sure what I
think it's okay in certain instances I
think you have to use it sparingly you
have to be able to do it guys moderate
you have to use it in moderation and
self-defense write those out writers
were dogpiling
that's like very important if he loses
that in that moment okay yeah it gets
back to vanos in like boom snap again
plus what were they gonna do the
thinnest you slap on the wrists like
well they just make them like into
peaceful dust which is like not a murder
yeah no it's a more cremation by Wow
alive
no this is how I want to be just as
painful isn't as he's shamed cold
have you had liquid nitrogen burning off
warts before I think there are some
superheroes that are like inextricably
linked to like not kill I think the
Batman's a bigger is a that might've
been bigger faux pas to have him killed
that's his whole credo I mean so his car
is built to kill in that much his car
has bloodlust so so you have take
offense at that you take less offense at
spider-man killing even though again he
is fresh into high school yeah well I
think he as we've mentioned he has
killed before with the snatcher again I
think there is something to I mean I
like the injustice games and comics like
and Kingdom Come like they did it like
Batman doesn't and Superman sometimes
does because there is sort of like for
the greater good element you say it's so
cheery I think a certain point like that
the the point is always made and this
probably might have been made in a third
Dark Knight movie had Heath Ledger lived
like the idea that like you have to stop
the madness at some point or else
innocent people just keep dying unless
you're able to be like I'm going to do
this because he will keep getting out
and keep killing so I'm gonna ask a
question here about the exact situation
that we were in series like maybe in
this specific situation it's okay in
this situation yeah he's got these
outriders all over him but also I'm
gonna call out the suit is not exactly
under his control we learned that from
homecoming right like if he says
something the suit kind of takes over
does the thing did spider-man kill them
or did the suit Oh God wait no because
he's saying sorry again
Spiner suit doesn't kill people I killed
spiders he activated the mode it didn't
work it's owner-operated man we should
put credit where credit suits the Waldos
right so Waldo is the murderer those are
the names so Where's Waldo should be in
prison it all comes back to eggs being
laid I think no no no and I think in
this moment spider-man isn't less of a
hero I think it shows his desperation
and panic in that moment sure I mean
yeah is Dexter here oh yes okay you're
so weird about this so excited no but I
don't mind the people he's killing as
long as I don't know about it I'm fine
that's a little bit of like that's you
know like I think this this is all just
like a reflection of our personal values
cuz like at the end oh yeah at the very
end of Game of Thrones which I'm sorry
if anybody hasn't seen it but come on
like her logic at the end CLE sees logic
at the end of like Jon Snow's like wait
so you just get to decide what's good
and bad and she was like yeah and that's
how I am I'm like yes I do get to decide
what's good or bad and and at that
moment when I was watching it I was like
oh I'm wrong Oh like he stabs her and I
was like oh no I'm the I'm the jerk you
would have got stabbed I would have
gotten step but that's like what I
believe like you have to have some
people who know what's right I know
what's wrong and they're willing to do
it it takes like Jack Bauer mm-hmm yes
right but in these scenarios no one is
serving as the judge other than the
executioner yeah that's why we need more
judge dreads
I keep saying it more judge dreads first
thing you ever said to me
screaming that's all I do
alright guys these are questions that I
don't know what they say and it's always
like a reading comprehension test for me
here but you guys will have to give us
your takes on these ready yes all right
Avengers end game screenwriters said
this week that they almost had a nose
show up for the final battle sitting on
a throne of skulls skulls Eric's skulls
what material would make an even more
uncomfortable throne than skulls swords
the eggshells of the homes that were not
yours but do you mean other people's
moms everyone else is someone else's mom
eggshells for moms you know I think the
this is my knee-jerk reaction it's
stupid the metal part of the brillo like
the brillo pad that's metal I believe
yeah I even touched it with your washing
dishes to be fair not too uncomfortable
if you just gently sit on it you just
can't no adjusting do you still know
this is not what it's for
what's a foreigner did not to sit on the
route you went on was like you know
steel wool it's not that comfortable to
sit on well nothing's too uncomfortable
you just easier way yeah like this chair
that you never get
so marina you got a different pitch yeah
you said the most intimidating right or
the weirdest I said the most
uncomfortable most uncomfortable would
be a bunch of dicks a bunch of dicks was
the most uncomfortable it would be the
most uncomfortable to sit on and it
would be the most uncomfortable to see
someone ride in on sorry but like how I
definitely did this already a thing on
the internet that we could look up the
Game of Thrones parody has to have a
throne of dates yeah you will sit on the
iron
the dildos not dicks they're not but
well in this case I thought about this
you guys were talking yes
there's enemy Photoshop we never got to
do this Trump one Clinton grass bean a
bunch of severed dick since like it was
it was essentially the thesis was r.i.p
patriarchy I like the else world onion
like that definitely should be a thing
yet we should steal guys last week
Captain America comics number one from
1941 sold for almost a million dollars
loser would you rather have a 1 million
dollar comic book or 1 million $1 comic
books
those million comic books okay we have
one real answer because no one's gonna
have my answer is one time my friend
gave out comic books for Halloween
instead of candy and the kids loved it
so you know obviously it's the million
dollar comic book but if you did have a
million to one dollar comic books you
can give them out in mail of ways I'm
saying it's obviously the million dollar
comic yeah I guess yeah Fremont you're
going change in the world you're trying
to make a quick buck yeah you could sell
a million dollars it's already been very
clearly valued please Ted this is worth
$1 sorry okay I have a different reason
for not wanting the million dollar comic
is I would be so terrified of something
happening to this one object
sell it I guess yeah sell it can we just
sit on this stupid with it with the
million comic books that are dollar you
put in my house somewhere but I probably
want to read it and then they'd be like
there's a drink very close to that
million dollar comic book and like I
just be very worried about something
happens you better read it it's not like
a one-of-a it doesn't not exist it's
just like a first edition I just I just
I don't like anything that's expensive
the hashtag hashtag
Batman yelp has been going viral this
week with people writing fake Yelp
reviews from Batman pitch me your best
off-the-cuff hashtag Batman yelp review
Joe Chill zero stars very sad instead
Joe chose definitely sounds like a
seafood need security Batman goes to the
LA Zoo too much sunshine enough caves
enough car wash Henry golden was cast as
Snake Eyes in a GI Joe spin-off
movie I'm gonna read off two names and
you tell me if it's a real GI Joe
character or a name that Austrian
producer just made up Scarlett yeah real
real sit on it real big red fake that's
a gun think it's a chewing gum incorrect
Oh giggle gun uh yeah real ass Stan from
there
[Music]
good it's like how barbie has a giggle
gun I'm like adorable I'm fake Oh
chuckles yeah chuckles all day long baby
not only is chuckles real chuckles is
getting his own movie yeah chuckles all
right
Flashdance sleeping on it fake sitting
on it standing
okay so Footloose is standing bridge
bridges done fridge sitting on it
because he's sitting on it the fridge
the fridge is fridge Perry refrigerator
oh it's William which is real actually
there's completely based on the football
player so big I didn't say much about
him but offensive lineman scored a
touchdown in a Super Bowl Bears versus
Patriots they die younger I'm gonna
stand
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so much for marina
what do you have going on in the world
sometimes you can see me with Eric new
rock stars and on your own yep
and I'm on Twitter at Marina monstrous
great you go you can find me
gallivanting around Hollywood yelling my
ideas for Field of Dreams to random
passerby on leo adrian garcia right you
can find me at EA vas is always and this
week coming up on new rock stars we have
some fun stuff marina and i will be in a
video coming out on Monday or Tuesday
next week and check out this weekend
because I love you notice this shirt
I'm going in down a crazy conspiracy
theory only in fictional worlds though
can we look into that Arnim Zola cameo
and Avengers endgame what the hell was
Howard Stark looking for him for and the
shirt was sent to us by our good friend
that MC you got UK on Twitter thanks man
this is great I don't have many shirts
jack of all shirts master guys I'm bill
Molina you can find me a poem aleena
pull up Molina everywhere I had tongue
surgery recently in that's true and I
can't say no else make sure to subscribe
to the channel but also to the podcast
version of this it always comes out
sooner on the podcast guys I think it's
appropriate that we do what inspires
everyone at the end of your high school
graduation and show that we can finally
stand and walk out on this nothing wrong
with being different
[Music]